The answer is no. This should definitely not be your next step. Why, you might
ask? Well, in order to get from this inequality to either one of these, we need
to effectively divide both sides by the factor that we're not using in the final
inequality we're looking at. Let's say that we wanted to get from this quadratic
inequality to looking at this linear one, x plus 4 is greater than zero. Well to
get x plus 4 by itself on the left side you would have to divide both sides of
the inequality by the quantity x minus 4, however we don't know what x is equal
to here and because of that we don't know what number we are dividing both sides
by, that means this variable could be a negative number and if that's the case.
We don't know which direction the final sign for x plus 4 is greater than 0
should actually point. So bottom line, this is not the approach we need to take.
We need to do something different.